on Prime crime
one of the darkest days in our nation's
history on a personal level
you as a dad I kind of have this guilt
like I should have known becomes a
battle for the truth
[Music]
[Music]
I wasn't able to keep my six-year-old
son safe so you can imagine somebody
going after my older son and there's
something that I can do about it I am
100 gonna do that this is a struggle
session are we in China I've already
apologized to the parents over and over
again
I apologize to you
foreign
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases in 2012 one
of the worst shootings in our nation's
history was carried out
but now imagine a loud voice coming out
and saying it never happened
December 14
2012 Newtown Connecticut reports of
gunfire at an elementary school suddenly
shatter the quiet and calm of this small
town community
John 9-1-1 what's the location of your
emergency Sandy Hook Elementary School
12 Dickinson Drive okay I've got that
what's going on down there this I
believe the shooting at the front at the
front glass something's going on all
right I want you to take cover so I was
at work in the hospital and I got a
phone call and so I sent it to voicemail
and then um but I had this weird feeling
because
um it was from it was from the school
district it was just a really just Curt
kind of cold message saying that all the
schools in Newtown have been put on
lockdown because of a reported shooting
a police emergency
I honestly didn't think anything other
being at an elementary school Alyssa on
the other hand being a fabulous mother
that she is I mean she called me right
away and she was really really worried
she knew that Emily's classroom was one
of the first classrooms as you enter
into the school
so there's no children in the library
with you there are but safe okay make
sure you lock the doors and all that
okay we have somebody on the way
I remember parking my car as I was
driving from work about a quarter of a
mile away I didn't realize the gravity
of what had happened I knew that there
had been a shooting at the school I was
thinking of domestic violence
event
[Music]
right now
when I arrived
it was obviously so much more I mean
they're they're the military was there
or people in in military uniforms uh
almost every police and ambulance in the
state had arrived do you have anybody
with you right now do you have any
children with you I have no children I
have five adults and one's been shot
twice
where are you
I mean the first conference okay are
they are they uh breathing and talking
to you she's breathing but she's barely
okay do you know
you fight outside the door please shut
100 shots
we had heard that there were children
that had been transported to the
hospital so I was trying to see if if
Emily had maybe come to the hospital
because we had been able to locate her
yet that's kind of how the news broke to
us in hell we first started coming to
terms in the end with what was happening
okay all right
I know you're I know you're you've got
to listen to me
foreign
take a deep breath okay think of your
children
remember your faces
try to stay calm you got to stay strong
for them okay thank you thank you the
police officers
okay okay all right you guys are okay
all right okay good people running
everywhere parents tearfully with their
children in their arms I ran and just
tried to find somebody that looked
official
and asked them if they had seen Jesse
Lewis I had
a State Trooper ask me for a picture of
Jesse and then he came back and he was
being nonchalant asking me for any
identifying marks on Jesse's body and I
remember thinking
oh he has a mole on the top of his right
foot
and this is not
it's not
a good question to be asking with a
positive outcome
it was just a slow Dawning over the
course of the next few hours without
being told anything that
Jesse wasn't coming back
the day would end in the deaths of 20
children six adult staff members the
shooter's mother and himself as well
Jesse was like a ball of fire he he had
so much energy bounced from couch to
couch he was very loud he was very
self-confident but he was also My Little
Cuddle Bunny and and just really just
just the sweetest
most incredible kid almost always with a
smile
the Sandy Hook elementary school
massacre has been considered one of the
worst mass shootings in American history
Emily was the epitome of what
childhood happiness and joy is all about
anybody that got an opportunity to meet
or be around Emily they always left with
a fun memory and when Emily was born I
was floored and totally shocked by how
much I could immediately love somebody
so intensely and it was almost like
scary on a personal level
you as a dad I kind of have this guilt
like I should have known I didn't even
know that I was
I was going to have to start grieving I
was scared that my daughter might have
gotten hurt or that she was just scared
while the nation reeled from the horror
of that day
something unexpected happened
uh let's talk to uh Kevin
Kevin uh go ahead you're on the air
hi I'll call about Danny hook uh
basically my take on it is I live about
50 miles from Newtown and the whole
thing is pretty much the next step in
reality TV you've got a bunch of people
walking around a parking lot it's pretty
much what it comes down to and none of
the others I've had the investigators on
I've had the state police have gone
public you name it it the whole thing is
a giant hoax this is Alex Jones one day
stage this I don't know
[Music]
the penguins live in Antarctica Jones is
the founder and host of infowars.com a
live streaming conspiracy theorist
website now you can watch The Alex Jones
show live at
half at infowars.com show you'll find
links to all of our content there and a
free 15-day trial for Prison Planet TV
if he sees something hit on his website
they'll try to emulate that they want to
repeat those spikes in traffic
and what we saw is that when he did his
first really big story on Sandy Hook his
own sort of homegrown version of this
lie then it actually became the third
most popular story on Infowars ever if
you've got a school of 100 kids and then
nobody can find them and you've got
parents laughing and then they walk over
to the camera
not just one but a bunch of parents
doing this and then photos of kids that
are still alive they said died I mean
they think we're so dumb that it's it's
really hidden in plain view immediately
after the Sandy Hook shooting Jones
began to promote the idea that this
wasn't real
semi-autos just as we knew they would do
you've heard me say look for a big mass
shooting at schools you gotta go with
your gut man my gut tells me I've never
felt this freaked out
I told my wife that last night this
morning and uh I really think they're
gonna try to come after the guns it's
going to start a civil war they knew
exactly how much this was resonating
With Their audience I mean they just had
the these sort of Perfect Storm of an
issue they knew Their audience cared
about which they tied to guns and this
Sensational story wrapped around an
event that a lot of people particularly
those with less firm grasp on reality
simply did not want to believe happened
and so it was it was just fodder for him
he again he didn't believe any of it but
it was something that could make him
money I said they are launching attacks
they're getting ready I can see them
warming up with Obama they've got a
bigger majority in the Congress now in
the Senate they are going to come after
our guns look for mass shootings and
then magically it happens we had just
been told that
we lived in a world where somebody was
capable of going into an elementary
school and opening fire on six-year-old
kids so you you just barely start to
wrap your head around the fact that
that's something that can happen and
that happened to you and we died Friday
morning and so within 48 hours I was
already introduced to this new
dimension of reality that we live in I
mean folks we've got video of Anderson
Cooper with clear blue screen out
he's not there in the Town Square we've
got people clearly coming up and and
laughing and then doing the fake crying
we've clearly got people where it's
actors playing different parts of
different people
when we come back Alex Jones's words
have dire results within 48 hours after
Emily dying to already start to get
attacked by a conspiracy theorists
spreading lies about me saying things
threatening my life threatening uh who I
am threat and questioning what happened
[Music]
it's not our government it's the
globalist all I know is thousands of
people have died in Mexico from Fast and
Furious many of them children so don't
ever think this couldn't be saved
after the 2012 Sandy Hook elementary
school shooting in Newtown Connecticut
resulting in the deaths of 20 children
and seven adults conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones immediately started casting
doubt on the authenticity of the mass
murder the general public doesn't know
the school was actually closed the year
before they don't know they've shielded
all demolished a building they don't
know that they have the kids going in
circles in and out of the building as a
photo op blue screen green screens but
it took me about a year with Sandy Hook
to come to grips with the fact that the
whole thing was fake I mean even I
couldn't believe it I knew they jumped
on it used the crisis hyped it up but
then I did deep research and my gosh it
just pretty much didn't happen and for
Jones and Infowars it was working
[Music]
to break down some exciting developments
in the area of research concerning
supplemental iodine
it's nothing less than phenomenal on
certain days when they would cover Sandy
Hook they would see almost a doubling of
sales on those days a doubling of
traffic they absolutely understood what
this story was doing for them from 2012
to 2022 the man has brought in 500
million dollars in Revenue selling these
products these supplements these
preparedness kits the prepackaged food
we were able to see the profit margins
that he had on that a man has a thousand
percent markup on these products and was
just pocketing all of that money what is
my what does the new magazine say you
can get it by subscribing and get 12
issues great way this man wants your
guns there was public polling showing
that nearly one in four Americans
believed that Sandy Hook was either
possibly or definitely staged and if you
think about that that's 75 million
Americans and Mr Jones was the only and
I mean this the only commercially
marketed media outlet that was pushing
these laws when I was
having that was what was so clear and
then
I think and then once and multiplayer
doing
me cry I mean it just it's just over the
top and we know they've changed other
stuff before he questioned my behavior
when I
gave up a public statement uh just to in
memory of Emily
I gave this kind of wry smile and did
this like nervous laugh
um
honestly that's just a way that I I try
and calm myself down so Alex Jones used
those three seconds of me having a very
human moment and he said that this isn't
behavior of somebody who just lost a
child making a pretty extreme claim that
would be a very thing Vivid in your
memory holding his dead child now here
is an account from the corner that does
not cooperate with that narrative that
was incredibly
painful I had held Jesse as well imagine
cradling your your dead son
and then having somebody mock you
in doing that it's just unimaginable
Jones's followers though weren't just
listening they were getting angry and
focusing their attention on the parents
who lost children that day these parents
when you start talking about something
like death threats right that that has
become a matter of routine for many of
them and there have been a large handful
of these folks who have done things like
desecrate the memorials to their
children who have shown up at their
homes there have been person who fired a
firearm outside of Neil's house Lenny
Posner was being stalked by a woman in
Central Florida
when after he had moved from Newtown
after too much harassment it was
Infowars who revealed that he had moved
to Boca Raton
I mean it's just ridiculous
yeah corners and started laughing and I
don't mean uncomfortably I
I'm laughing
[Music]
because I mean it just is the faintest
thing since the three dollar bill
and you better get ready for more of it
folks
initially it was just stuff that was
online comments online saying like you
know you're gonna burn in hell but then
when they start sending letters to your
home they know where you live and they
start to say like we're watching you
you got the actor father who and then he
walks out and then he's and then he's
totally sad crying you just cracking
jokes right before that's an actor
as an actor the best example that I have
four years after the shooting and I'm
walking down the street and this guy
just notices me and um so I stop and and
he asks me didn't you have a child that
died and I said yes I was like my oldest
daughter she was a victim at Sandy Hook
Elementary School and he he just stared
at me and
he had the most hateful look in his face
and he just
how do you sleep at night you fucking
son of a and he just started spouting
all of these things that I had heard
Alex Jones say on on his broadcast so I
turn around and I start walking in the
other direction
and he follows me for blocks swearing
swearing swearing I finally
spoke up and defended myself and
defended who Emily was I'll stay staged
Aurora they staged Sandy Hook the
evidence is just overwhelming somebody's
got to tell you the truth somebody's got
to stand against these people at Jesse's
wake
there were
thousands of people it was amazing how
many people came
but also the different types of of
individuals
including a biker gang and I thought
well the world is mourning but then
later found out that they were there
ironically to keep the peace because a
group had filed a petition or or filed
for a permit to protest the children's
funerals
the signs are there and they're going to
blame it on us and we've got to
instantly come out and not take the
guilt they put on us phone calls
emails upsetting emails about your son
and death threats one in particular
targeted
my my older son I wasn't able to keep my
six-year-old son safe Jesse
so you can imagine somebody going after
my older son and there's something that
I can do about it I am 100 gonna do that
coming up these parents take action I
will not perjure myself out of the
orders of a judge this has never before
been done in U.S history it's a struggle
session right out of communist China or
South Africa this is serious tyranny
foreign
okay
the Sandy Hook Elementary School
shooting resulted in the deaths of
multiple children and adults and left
families in a community in Devastation
but that wasn't all in the aftermath
Infowars founder and host Alex Jones
promulgated the theory that this
shooting was staged
deal with a total hoax I mean it's just
how do you even convince the public
something's a total hoax but remember
this is the same White House that's been
caught running the fake Bin Laden raid
people just instinctively know
yeah there's a lot of fraud going on
in that first week I already started to
become fearful of
of the attacks that people were saying
to me when I get an email from somebody
a few days after Emily has died talking
about how if they ever see me they want
to bash my head in with a baseball bat I
have to take that very very seriously
after Jones's comments started
circulating victims family members
became the subject of intense harassment
and there were Targets on their backs
and so much transpired when we talk
about this conspiracy world within that
first week receiving these threats to
where you're making plans with
uh how you're going to handle security
at a funeral home in case anything
happens I mean that's the most absurd
thing that you can think about when all
you want to do is just remember who your
daughter is and about 10 minutes before
the funeral home is going to open the
doors I was trying to find Alyssa there
and somebody said you need to come here
and there was this coat closet and she's
sitting down on the floor of the quote
closet and she's wrapped up she's just
bawling and she said like I just don't
know if I can do this
now as time went on and the years went
by Alex Jones would eventually attempt
to backtrack and recant his statements
on Father's Day I want to reach out to
the parents of the slain children it's a
horrible tragedy in Newtown Connecticut
and give you my sincere condolences but
it was too late beginning in 2018
lawsuits against Alex Jones and his
company were launched alleging claims
from defamation to intentional
infliction of emotional distress the
immediate concern was getting him to
stop that's part of the motivation for
what brought these parents to finally
bring suit is particularly when they saw
Parkland happen and they saw Mr Jones
inventing the same formula he came out
that day said Parkland is a false flag
to start a civil war just repeating the
exact same formula which brought him
money from the Sandy Hook shooting
that's when the parents knew they had to
speak up but Jones did something curious
or rather chose not to do something I'm
not the Sandy Hook man I've already said
I was sorry years and years ago I've
already tried to make restitution
they're using this case to go after the
first amendment
there has been basically a Lynch Mob to
get Alex Jones since Trump got elected
over the course of several different
cases Mr Jones is being non-compliant
with very basic Discovery orders
it wouldn't be on just the amount of
documents he should produce or the
videos it went even into when they were
asked to appear for deposition and the
judge kept giving them time and time and
time again it wasn't until the discovery
abuse had gotten so egregious or they
were discovered that they had fabricated
evidence had concealed documents
knowingly that's when the judge finally
entered a default judgment and what's
Wild is the exact same thing happened in
the Connecticut lawsuits so to have a
defendant who somehow managed through
absolute refusal to participate to get
themselves defaulted in two separate
jurisdictions at the same time
completely unprecedented in American
history how much he has thumbed his nose
in the court is truly unbelievable this
means that by law Alex Jones
automatically lost these lawsuits and
therefore is liable they're taking away
your rights and your freedom to a fair
trial judges shouldn't find people
liable or guilty juries should do that I
think Alex Jones knew he he was going to
be found liable for defamation I think
he made a strategic decision I think the
stuff he didn't produce is so bad that
he thought it would be better to be
found liable by default where at least
he could complain that the courts were
being unfair that it would be to
actually produce the evidence but I
think he didn't want anybody to see that
and that's why he did what he did the
only question that remained is how much
would he have to pay up
compensatory damages can be based on the
harm suffered by the victim sometimes
there's out-of-pocket Financial harm but
the jury can also put a financial number
on pain and suffering punitive damages
are intended to punish the defendant for
their bad Acts when we return these
trials end up going places no one could
have imagined
attorneys how many times do I have to
say when I'm speaking you stop what do I
need to do to stop the comments and the
call just tell me what I need to do do I
need to hold one of you in contempt
foreign
[Music]
Hitler blow up the rice tag to get
control why did government stage these
things to get our guns I mean why can't
people get that through their head
Ten Years After the horror of the Sandy
Hook Elementary School shooting Infowars
host and conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
finds himself on trial multiple people
who lost loved ones in the massacre and
even a former FBI agent Sue Jones in
Connecticut and Texas for various claims
such as defamation after he repeatedly
and publicly called the mass shooting a
hoax no emergency helicopters were sent
the ambulances came an hour and a half
later and parked down the road DHS an
hour and a half later with a time stamp
put up signs saying sign in here they
had porta potties being delivered within
an hour and a half it looked like a
carnival
looked like a big PR stunt we have the
emails from city council back and forth
and the school talking about it being
shut down a year before
we have the school then being demolished
and the records being sealed
we have videos uh that look just just
incredibly suspicious where people are
laughing and everything and they start
huffing and puffing and start crying on
TV which is pure acting method
Alex Jones would lose these cases by
default judgment for failing to comply
with Discovery obligations the only
question that remained for these juries
was how much would they order him to pay
out in Damages
this man knew
that parents of murdered children
emotionally distressed
and he looked straight into that camera
and he said the only problem is I've
lost a lot of someone
seen actors
it just kept going it doesn't stop
2017.
and it's still going they're still
making videos saying this phony is a
three dollar bill Alex Jones
has already been punished he lost
all his access
to the internet millions of dollars
he regrets what he did to know the
importance of standing up to police
when they prey on people who are
helpless and profit from them
and to know that unless you stop it
bully a bully will never stop himself
our contention to be clear is that the
damage claims here are exaggerated
because of the idiosyncratic motives in
the place transforming their griefs into
Political weapons
Jones's best defense was to show that he
didn't cause incremental damage to the
plaintiffs to start with they were all
family members of victims in these
school shootings one could argue they
were already subject to as much
emotional distress as you could be what
he said didn't really matter he could
argue on Damages that none of them
suffered substantial out of pocket
damages meaning they didn't have to
spend specific sums of money in response
to things he had said so that the dollar
amounts weren't that high
to say The Alex Jones trials were
different would be an understatement
things happen that no one could have
predicted including one moment that was
caught on camera after court had ended
for the day there was not great
relations of opposing counsel but with
Mr right now it was particularly
abrasive and the first time that Andino
and I ever talked was outside the
courthouse on the courthouse steps and
he told me at that time
in a sort of mocking way you know your
your clients are never going to get a
dime ah what do you think about that I I
knew what I was dealing with here was
different than the kind of lawyer I
would normally deal with and that
manifested itself at trial will you talk
to me and you know we talked to him
are all your videos on the summary
guys maybe now's not the time maybe we
can cool off we don't have a phone call
later you come after a day in court
which did not go very well for them and
towards the end of it particularly we
were able to launch several objections
to to their evidence which they had not
prepared properly for trial and Andino
did not like that I had this
confrontation that was unlike anything
I've ever had in a courtroom I mean it
actually reminded me of um oh I'm in
eighth grade again because all of a
sudden there's this man you know getting
up on my personal space like he's gonna
have a fight with me it was it was
comical to me at the time and and I
think some of my humor at that is what
made him even matter is that I'm not
taking this like this is an actual
physical confrontation the judge had
said on the record look if that had
happened in my presence you'd be looking
at contempt right now
but the real fireworks began when Alex
Jones showed up
Mr Jones It's Not now what is it I I had
my tooth pulled uh a week and a half ago
and it's I had some thoughts earlier so
you're chewing on your gauze would you
like to show you no I'm sure I don't
want to see her inside of your mouth I
guess to put it kindly you can say he
was defiant if you wanted to be less
kind you could say he was petulant this
is a Witch Hunt this is a show trial
this will go down in history as one of
the greatest show trials ever to have
but not just here but even in places
like Nazi Germany we tell clients all
the time be quiet don't say anything to
the Press we fight our battles in the
court not out of court but here Alex
Jones wanted to do exactly the opposite
he was there solely for his out-of-court
strategy of publicity and fundraising
you encourage your audience to give you
money is in cryptocurrency donations
right yes in fullhorse.com
stuff as they put on your show tonight
he is trying to keep the money flow
coming in by pretending to be the real
victim here
freedom
don't you ever not realize how important
you are and I'm talking to people that
went to that puppet courthouse in
Connecticut and put in four stickers up
everywhere we commend you
while Jones would make outrageous
statements on his show into the media
testifying under oath is a whole other
story and the World At Large saw Jones
doing just that when he testified in
both the Texas and Connecticut trials
have you been wanting to
apologize to the plaintiffs in this case
for a long time yes and what would you
like to say to them
that I never intentionally tried to hurt
you your belief at that time that
no one died at Sandy Hook that the whole
thing was fake
do you understand as you sit here today
how crazy that is there have been so
many lives and so many things in the
past and I was under a lot of pressure
and I truly when I said those statements
when I say something I mean it
that I really couldn't believe that it
was totally staged that point do you
understand now that it is absolutely
irresponsibility it was especially since
I met the parents and
it's it's 100 real in fact at one point
Jones actually tried to apologize to
plain of Scarlett Lewis and Neil
hesliner
videos anymore
I think he was genuine I I absolutely do
I believe that he is sorry uh for for
all the Sandy Hook stuff I believe also
however that he has this Burning Desire
to satisfy an audience that has
expectations of him yet this is just the
beginning up next something happens at
trial that's still hard to believe
you know
I just want to make sure you know before
we go any further you know what it is
yes I do I mean I'm not a Tech Guy
please remember
I think Sandy Hook happened
and I think it's a terrible event and I
think we need to protect our children
in 2022 10 years after the Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting Infowars
founder and host Alex Jones is in the
witness box in two different trials the
plaintiffs primarily those who lost
loved ones in the massacre successfully
sued in won judgments against Jones
after he made claims that the shooting
was fake and staged the question for
these juries is how much would they
order Jones to pay in Damages while
Jones testified that he took ownership
and responsibility for the false
statements got my head cleaned up
realized that it probably did happen and
I was probably I mean it was a good
chance I was wrong so I started
basically trying to walk it back long
before I got sued at the same time Jones
and his attorneys argued he shouldn't
have to pay out that much and what
didn't the plaintiff's lawyers tell you
they told you you're the conscious of
the community you know hold Alex
accountable make a point they never
talked about the damage you heard from
no physician you saw no medical bill you
heard nothing about a lost wage no
receipt for anything has been put before
you but when pressed by opposing lawyers
another side of Alex Jones came out you
taking the straw seriously you're
approaching it in good faith
absolutely sometimes you Maya gamble
comes from CPS who has been exposed to
Human
trials
that's what you mean when you say you're
taking it seriously
I take this as serious as cancer the
person on the left of this image is our
judge correct yes the person on the
right is another judge you don't like
right yes okay
and kidding let's just say this
extremely blue collar folks I mean half
that jury panel does not know who I am
it's people do live in all these
different Bubbles and there's the
bubbles that are awake and the bubbles
that are questioning but then there's
the blue City bubbles
where people do not know what planet
they are on Mr Jones you don't like that
this jury is made up of blue color tote
you think that's wrong no I don't think
that
I'm glad that Alex Jones when he showed
up I'm I think he did show his true
colors and he showed who he really was
he is a man that is incapable of any
sort of compassion or remorse or fails
to be apologetic in a sincere way
real Robbie Parker isn't it
I mean I said years ago again
I'm sitting right here he's real isn't
he yes you put a Target on his back just
like you did every
every parent and loved one sitting here
no I didn't just like all the Iraqis but
you liberals kill and love
just you're unbelievable
you switch on emotions on and off when
you want you're it's just ambulance
chasing
why don't you show a little respect you
have families in this program here that
lost children Sisters Wives
moms
this is a struggle session are we in
China
I've already said I'm sorry hundreds of
times and I'm done saying I'm sorry but
I legitimately thought it might have
been staged and I stand by that I don't
apologize for it and don't apologize Mr
Jones please go to college now I've
already apologized to the parents over
and over again
but there was one moment where everyone
froze do you know where I got this no
Mr Jones
for that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorney's messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed did not take any steps to
identify it as privileged or protected
in any way and as of two days ago it
fell free and clear into my possession
and that is how I know you lied to me
when you said you didn't have a text
message about Sandy Hook I still can't
convince myself of exactly what happened
there there was no any indication why
these documents are being sent to us and
it seemed to me that there was just a
pure out mistake that's when I contacted
Mr rain on and said hey look I think you
sent this to me inadvertently he said to
just disregard the link at first and
then 10 days passed and no documents are
identified as privileged but as a result
of this colossal mix-up it actually
revealed a lot of the the games that
they had been playing I told you the
truth this is your Perry Mason moment I
gave them my phone and I'm going to tell
you one hundred percent he did not know
I don't believe he had been briefed in
any way about this disclosure and I also
believe that Mr Reynold's reaction to me
after the cross-examination where he
went into a panic and wanted to know all
what was disclosed I believe that was
genuine as well you had a lawyer who was
not on top of what was happening at all
that is how your client gets embarrassed
on a national stage
up next the remarkable conclusion to The
Alex Jones legal Saga and then I got on
the stand and Alex was sitting in front
of me and I just looked into his eyes
for a long time
and I was not going to break
the the eye contact
[Music]
because your credibility sir is the most
important thing with your audience isn't
it no my most important okay no your
credibility is not your most important
it's crushing the globalist crushing
globalists
it's 2022 and Infowars founder and host
Alex Jones finds himself in two
different courtrooms in both Connecticut
and Texas the plaintiffs primarily the
families of those who lost loved ones in
the Sandy Hook Elementary School
shooting successfully sue Jones for his
repeated comments that the massacre
never happened and was staged what do
you make of the green screen with
Anderson Cooper down there on the ground
what do you make of the obvious stage
they're used and had multiple actors
playing the part of multiple people I
mean this is undoubted something's going
on the juries in both of these cases had
to decide how much Jones should pay out
in Damages to compensate the plaintiffs
for the harm they suffered and also
whether to punish Jones Not only would
Jones attorneys argue the claims were
exaggerated but Jones himself went on
the defense in sometimes colorful
fashion both in court did you make money
off of your Sandy Hook coverage
no we lost money it really hurt us I
almost didn't air the tape of the head
of state police saying there's a
cover-up in evolved even if I'm sure
children die is terrible but I'm like
hands off now because I don't want to be
sucked into this black hole of mass
shootings anymore and now
how's it going
everybody enjoying the show trial for
all the attention brought to Alex Jones
these cases always centered on the
plaintiffs what you saw in that school
fake no no
I'm
pathetic
there's children real
oh
for 27 years of my life
that woman was my best friend
and for people to tell me that she
didn't exist
let that happen makes you feel like you
don't matter
do you feel like what you went through
doesn't matter so you're not going to
stop
I don't even think my pleading with you
up here is going to get you to stop and
all of the damage that you've caused
there has to be accountability for that
you don't understand the repercussions
to individuals lives you don't
understand and I don't think you will
understand unless there's some form of
punishment that is significant that
would make you understand that this is
real I just started talking to him I
could see the fear in his eyes I run the
Choose Love movement Jesse my
six-year-old son left a message on our
kitchen chalkboard
before he died three words nurturing
healing love and in the moment I
literally consciously practice that
formula which is the formula for
choosing love and saw Alex for what he
truly was which is just simply a human
being in pain not getting it right
making mistakes it turned out that
Choose Love was really the theme of the
lawsuit my attorney asked the jury to
choose love
over
hatred and fear and they did
question number one
four million two hundred thousand
dollars
question number two
million five hundred thousand dollars
that Texas jury would end up awarding
the plaintiffs in that case almost 50
million dollars
but then there was Connecticut two
plaintiff Robbie Parker a defamation
slash slander damages past his future 60
million dollars
B emotional distress damages pass to
teachers 60 million dollars it was this
huge weight lifted off me in the sense
of like
I finally felt like I had been seen and
I had been hurt that all of this stuff
that I've been going through
somebody saw that and they recognized
how bad it was and they recognized how
atrocious it was and and the harm that
it did to me and my family and they said
I see that and I want you to know that I
see that David wheeler 55 million
dollars
who played this Francine wheeler total
54 million dollars to Plaintiff
Jacqueline Barton 28 million 800 000 57
million six hundred thousand dollars
seventy three million six hundred
thousand dollars in total the jury
awarded the plaintiffs in Connecticut
965 million dollars but that's not all
Judge Barbara Bellis imposed an
additional Award of
473 million dollars for punitive damages
total 54 million dollars
28 million eight hundred thousand
dollars get those numbers up billion
dollars owed by Alex Jones I personally
don't have two million dollars the
company's almost completely out of money
we're in bankruptcy there's two appeals
it'll take years there's caps on almost
all of this this is just completely
absolutely made up
how much will he pay when this is all
said and done it depends on knowing the
outcomes of so many contingent things
about how the bankruptcy goes how this
how the state court appeals will go how
any negotiations go in the future both
sets of plaintiffs have solid arguments
to evade the statutory caps we're gonna
have two more trials and two more
verdicts that what this shows you is
that ultimately there will be a large
group of plaintiffs 20 of them who are
going to be dividing up the corpse of
Infowars and splitting in among
themselves the message is a very good
one and it's very important to the
future of our society
the message is about the importance of
truth truth is our reality and anything
but truth is not reality somehow my wife
and I and our family were still standing
of course it's complicated because
there's still grief involved there's
still conspiracy theories involved but
we are able to get back a lot from this
experience and I'm glad that we did it
because of that
it's incredible to think about how this
was a 10-year Journey for these
plaintiffs and Alex Jones himself and
yes there's still more litigation and
the fight over whether any money will
actually be paid out looks like it won't
be an easy one and may even get ugly but
nothing changes the impact and the
message that was sent by these juries to
Alex Jones and the country at large and
that message is that words have
consequences
thanks for joining us here on Prime
crime until next time stay safe
[Music]
foreign